-The musical "Hamilton"
is a story about
hope, revolution, and love,
a story as relevant now
as it was back then.
Here is me and The Roots
performing "Helpless"
with some instruments
around the house,
plus Lin-Manuel Miranda
and the original Broadway cast
of "Hamilton."
Hey.
-Hey.
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ I do, I do, I do, I dooo ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ I do, I do, I do, I dooo ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Boy, you got me helpless ♪
♪ Look into your eyes,
and the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm helpless ♪
♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
-♪ I have never been the type to
try and grab the spotlight ♪
♪ We were at a revel with some
rebels on a hot night ♪
♪ Laughin' at my sister
as she's dazzling the room ♪
♪ Then you walked in,
and my heart went ♪
-"Boom!"
-♪ Tryin' to catch your eye from
the side of the ballroom ♪
♪ Everybody's dancin',
and the band's top volume ♪
-♪ Grind to the rhythm as we
wine and dine ♪
-♪ Grab my sister and whisper,
"Yo, this one's mine" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ My sister made her way
across the room to you ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ And I got nervous, thinking,
"What's she gonna do?" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ She grabs you by the arm,
I'm thinkin', "I'm through" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ Then you look back at me,
and, suddenly, I'm helpless! ♪
♪ Oh, look at those eyes ♪
-♪ Look into your eyes,
and the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm helpless ♪
-♪ I know ♪
-♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
♪ Helpless ♪
-♪ I am so into you ♪
-♪ Look into your eyes,
and the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm helpless ♪
-♪ I know I'm ♪
-♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
-♪ One week later,
I'm writin' a letter nightly ♪
♪ Now my life gets better
every letter that you write me ♪
♪ Laughin' at my sister 'cause
she wants to form a harem ♪
-I'm just sayin', if you really
loved me, you would share him.
-Ha!
-♪ Two weeks later,
in the living room stressin' ♪
♪ My father's stone-faced
while you're asking
for his blessin' ♪
-♪ I'm dying inside
as you wine and dine ♪
♪ And I'm tryin' not to cry
'cause there's nothing that
your mind can't do ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ My father makes his way
across the room to you ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ I panic for a second,
thinking, "We're through" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ But then he shakes
your hand and says, "Be true" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ And you turn back
to me, smiling ♪
-♪ Helpless ♪
♪ Look into your eyes,
and the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm helpless ♪
♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
♪ Helpless ♪
-♪ That boy is mine ♪
♪ That boy is mine ♪
-♪ Look into your eyes,
and the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm helpless ♪
-♪ Helpless ♪
-♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
-♪ Eliza, I don't
have a dollar to my name ♪
♪ An acre of land, a troop to
command, a dollop of fame ♪
♪ All I have's my honor,
a tolerance for pain ♪
♪ A couple of college credits
and my top-notch brain ♪
♪ Insane, your family brings out
a different side of me ♪
♪ Peggy confides in me, Angelica
tried to take a bite of me ♪
♪ No stress, my love for you
is never in doubt ♪
♪ We'll get a little place in
Harlem and we'll figure it out ♪
♪ I've been livin' without
a family since I was a child ♪
♪ My father left, my mother
died, I grew up buck-wild ♪
♪ But I'll never forget my
mother's face, that was real ♪
♪ And long as I'm alive, Eliza,
swear to God,
you'll never feel so ♪
-♪ Helpless ♪
-♪ I do, I do, I do, I dooo ♪
-♪ Eliza ♪
-♪ Helpless ♪
-♪ I never felt so ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, ♪
-♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
-♪ My life is only fine
'cause Eliza's in it ♪
-♪ I look into your eyes,
and the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm ♪
-♪ Helpless ♪
♪ Down for the count,
and I'm drownin' in 'em ♪
-Hey.
-♪ Boy, you got me helpless ♪